hey guys player one here with a GameSpot
news update
player two here if you thought
split-screen multiplayer was dying 343
industries might have just hammered the
final nail and the couch co-op coffin
the next game in the Halo series series
known for its split-screen multiplayer
will not have any split-screen after
quite a bit of heat from fans 343
industries have given an explanation
behind the tough decision in a post on
Halo Waypoint the developer said
dropping split-screen was an incredibly
tough decision but explained it was
necessary to provide the best experience
to players executive producer Josh Homme
said the decision to remove split-screen
support from halo 5 Guardians with one
of the most difficult ones we've ever
had to make as a studio to move halos
gameplay forward and deliver a true
next-gen experience tough choices had to
be made our decision was driven by a
desire for scale fidelity and focus to
ensure we would deliver the best quality
experience possible
many of our ambitious goals for Halo 5
would be compromised in a split-screen
setting and the time spent optimizing
and addressing split-screen traffic
issues would take focus from building
other parts of the game the halo 5
release date is set for October 27th
exclusively for Xbox ones well that
sucks
hey come on go play rocket League yeah
for the latest news be sure to head the
GameSpot comm
you
[Music]